EFFECTIVENESS.
I WISH YOU GOOD LUCK AND
EFFECTIVENESS IN INFLUENCING THE
PEOPLE THERE.
DENNIS, LET ME END ON THIS.
YOU DO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THIS MAN.
YOU'VE SAID IT MANY TIMES.
>> YES.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU GET IT TO
SPEAK UP FOR THE FAMILY OF
KENNETH BAE AND SAY, LET US KNOW
WHY THIS MAN IS BEING HELD?
IF YOU CAN HELP THEM, WILL YOU
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY?
>> WATCH THIS.
THE ONE THING ABOUT POLITICS,
KENNETH BAE DID ONE THING, IF
YOU UNDERSTAND -- IF YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT KENNETH BAE DID,
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT HE DID?
>> WHAT DID HE DO?
YOU TELL ME.
>> IN HIS COUNTRY.
>> YOU TELL ME.
YOU TELL ME.
WHY IS HE HELD CAPTIVE.
>> THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED ANY
CHARGES.
THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED ANY
REASON.
>> LISTEN.
LISTEN.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SPEAK ON
THIS.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU GOTTEN GUYS
HERE -- TEN GUYS HERE THAT HAVE
LEFT THEIR FAMILIES, LEFT THEY
FAMILIES TO HELP THIS COUNTRY IN
A SPORTS VENTURE.
TEN GUYS, ALL THESE GUYS HERE.
DO ANYONE UNDERSTAND THAT?
>> WE DO.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
>> CHRISTMAS -- I DON'T GIVE
[ BLEEP ] LOOK AT THESE GUYS.
LOOK AT THEM.
>> DON'T USE THEM AS AN EXCUSE
FOR THE BEHAVIOR THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING ON YOURSELF.
YOU JUST BASICALLY WERE SAYING
THAT KENNETH BAE DID SOMETHING
WRONG.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
CHARGES ARE.
>> LISTEN.
LISTEN.
>> I GOT IT.
LET ME DO THIS.
LET ME -- LET ME.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ONE THING.
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD --
AROUND THE WORLD -- I'M GOING TO
DO ONE THING.
YOU DON'T DIE BEHIND THE MIC
RIGHT NOW.
THE GUYS HERE DO ONE THING.
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO AMERICA
AND TAKE THE ABUSE.
WE GOING TO TAKE.
DO YOU, SIR, LET ME KNOW -- WE
GOING TO GET IT.
BUT GUESS WHAT